Speaker 1: Another interesting story, legal
story related to the failed former president
that I briefly want to talk about.
A judge has ruled that Donald Trump indeed
must give evidence in this defamation lawsuit
related to alleged rape by Donald Trump.
The Hill reports a federal judge has denied
former President Trump's motion to pause the
proceedings of a defamation suit against him
from a woman who has accused him of rape.
While appeals over the case play out, setting
him up for a deposition next week.
This is I know Trump was recently deposed
by Letitia James.
This is another deposition in another case.
Now, as a reminder, this is not a criminal
rape case.
This is a lawsuit for defamation related to
the things Donald Trump said about a rape
accuser.
Eugene Carroll, U.S. District Judge Rights,
The Hill.
Lewis Kaplan ruled yesterday that Trump's
argument didn't meet the legal threshold required
for a stay to be issued.
Trump has been pushing for the U.S. to be
substituted in Jean Carroll's lawsuit against
him because the comments Trump made denying
her claim and criticizing her happened when
he was President.
Trump's argument is I shouldn't be the defendant
in this lawsuit for the things I said about
Jean Carroll, including, if I recall correctly,
that she's not really his type.
As if that's a reason, rather than saying,
I don't rape people.
He said, she's not my type.
It doesn't make sense that I would have raped
her insane.
He says he was president at the time and thus
really the federal government should be the
defendant rather than him.
The Hill notes the details of the case here.
Carroll accused Trump of raping her at a manhattan
department store in the nineties.
Trump has countered by accusing Carroll of
lying and making remarks criticizing her appearance.
Yeah, Trump requested that proceedings in
the defamation case that Carroll filed be
paused while the D.C.
Court of Appeals weighs whether Trump was
acting in his official capacity.
When I said she was too ugly to rape, I was
functioning in an official capacity.
So the federal government should be the defendant.
That's where we are in 2022 at this point
in time, Kaplan wrote in his ruling.
The court could rule either way on the question,
but Trump gave no reason for him to conclude
that the ruling would be in his favor.
He also found that Trump failed to show a
meaningful, meaningful threat of irreparable
injury if a stay is not put in place.
Listen, you can't sue me for defamation because
I was acting in my official capacity as president
at that time.
Now, what do we expect he will do?
If indeed he is deposed.
Probably plead the Fifth.
At his last deposition with Letitia James,
Trump pled the fifth about 400 times.
Trump previously has said only the mob pleads
the fifth.
You don't plead the fifth if you're innocent.
His own experience with the deposition changed
his mind on that, surprisingly.
The important thing to remember is that as
a defendant in a civil suit, pleading the
Fifth may not be as useful to him as it can
be in a criminal case.
I heard from a criminal defense attorney who
said, you know.
In this is a criminal defense attorney who
wrote to me and said, David, sir, with tears
in his eyes.
He said, David, sir, when I defend people
criminally.
Juries are given instructions that the lack
of testimony from my client or pleading the
Fifth cannot be used to draw negative inferences
or to point towards guilt.
You can't hold against them that they don't
testify or that they pled the Fifth in a civil
lawsuit.
Trump or whoever.
Pleading the Fifth or refusing to answer questions
can be used to draw a negative inference.
And theoretically, as part of a guilty verdict,
we're thinking many steps ahead, but an important
difference in terms of civil versus criminal.
Now, I know many of you were wondering what
about the criminal aspect of this?
To be honest, I don't know where that stands.
I know that there are questions as the statute
of limitations.
This alleged event happened during the nineties
and a number of other obstacles.
But what we are dealing with right now is
a civil suit for defamation, wherein I'm sort
of breaking this down to its its kernel of
truth.
Trump sort of said Aegean, Carol, is not attractive
enough for me to actually have raped.
She's not my type, which is a crazy thing
to say.
We'll have more on this and other stories
from today on her Instagram.
You can find that at David Pakman show.
And we will be right back after this short
break.